[Music]
welcome to Osaka the final destination
for our journey appropriately it's a
city where the old has given way to the
new an ancient castle stand proudly
alongside modern business towers in the
first episode of the series we explored
what resident evil used to be its impact
on game design and how Indies have
reinvigorated the horror genre in its
languishing years for this our second
and final chapter Capcom has invited us
to its hometown otaku culture is the
lifeblood here it streets hum with j-pop
drifting out of packed anime stores
arcades are in rude health and retro
game stores proudly showcased Japan's
extensive gaming legacy this bright
friendly scene you might seem like an
unlikely place for the home of Resident
Evil but this is where it was born for
it evolved and where it's been a
mutating for the past 20 years and it's
where Capcom has been experimenting with
Resident Evil 7 taking pods from its
most acclaimed survival horror tiles and
stitching him to a new skeleton creating
a chimera that he hopes will terrify a
whole new generation of players after
speaking with the development team a
veritable all-star cast comprising
veterans and visionaries from numerous
Resident Evil titles it became clear
that for Capcom reconnecting with
Resident Evil's past was the key to its
future the series is returned to its
survival-horror roots comes at a time
when Indies have wrestled control away
from blockbuster franchises which begs
the question is Resident Evil still
relevant
[Music]
[Music]
no by others vitality Iran hero
character home 21-gun salute oh you may
know you're tied or adapted to survive
our Ohana so we tie me kangaroo kioku
yoshi Aramis took you on as a Christian
I add on a book that's more but actual
in Kolkata biohazard on Academy toe
survivor of irani model Rio Haddad okay
towards could eat I'd to Omega most so
in every ching-kuo given route so to the
meeting announce tables to arrange a
negative so yep a mudra Amazon biohazard
whole coyote Siddiqui grab a 2-0
directive Arsenal model change denier
muzzle canina a person no de llamada a
scooter are a Buddhist it's good the
opportunity to vote or take colonies to
chronicle sequester
hello so shoot me so Colleen oh my god
who are sweetie
a transcriber
speaking to the developers the message
that Resident Evil was finally returning
to its roots again began to take on an
apologetic tone almost as if it was an
unspoken agreement that yes in the years
following Resident Evil 4 the shifting
focus to fast-paced action had
compromised the franchise's identity
[Music]
the context of survival horror Capcom is
now operating within has been defined
not by the Titans of the genre but by
independent developers and Studios
without a survival horror legacy the
influence games such as alien isolation
slender outlast and amnesia have had on
Resident Evil 7 is undeniable these
games alongside other smaller indie
titles have changed the language of
horror design it's telling that when
forced to reinvent Resident Evil and
Silent Hill two of the most recognizable
horror franchises in gaming both Capcom
and Konami with PT independently arrived
at the same conclusions they need to
pull back on scale and bombast in favour
of dense detail rich environments that
emphasize atmosphere through a
first-person perspective though Saburo
hora omo instead oh it's good to come
later - keenie biohazard own money
models the vehicle a machinist missing
June a nanny to stay misogyny at a
survivor of Rod Carew Tamiya dorita
mistress nan de muro de un testigo it's
kara biohazard all survivor Oh Hani
still kutiman in sunomono Naru
the auto can write a conch I know fast
passed on butyl to get the moon
economists models to can live this motto
every game me its catalytic
he could do that Soto book that's really
attack Sakana
most of Shiva cool look at the can write
a teeny
so you've every one of us possum you
know should I give Dominic or consignee
gotta area no game will not be machine
learning our first apostle Bureau stay
where under you to stiva
very small bar in a nominal a connection
or a designee really tight end Akira no
so there's no
y una hora Amiga at proto-man habitat
you knowa
joining team unit of the trustees
matatini biohazard oh god could pierce a
viable hora en route Oh in my in this
game for our game di giotto are not
empty eye socket anatomist survivor
horatora Sagara for America who ototoxic
qf Cardona guarantee no Honoka cotton
anezka sabudana vada moto moto active
any eco finita 800 Agata Kanaka tiger ii
oh god couscous aloha tama da da - so
etomidate biohazard of the Yamuna Jonah
system you know game terrazzo casa o
clock atomic hora kiraku today are
etomidate survive Aurora demo can I do
to Modesto
sweet amiga Casa Cosmo for our game mary
did appear on metastasis he's only in
Korea
[Applause]
[Music]
just like games movies have largely left
the cheap scares of lurching zombies and
grotesque monsters behind in favor of
visceral found-footage flicks such as
wreck or the control tension of
paranormal activity while Capcom is
bringing the franchise in line with
modern game design trends its
storytelling and tonal influences are
firmly rooted in classic Hollywood
horror
I'm talking about ability to take a
stand for meat I know success Tecna Edo
Shogunate oka a top to tie division a no
ego no skeleton key
it was funny and no but I'm eating meat
across some corny inspiration get this
ringy and I orthodontist oh holy mother
t8o Quad Cities what could unique
honesty at all fighters demonic aura
Corrado Stephen King which I found out
today I know
so this nail polish many many shiny
Inglot oka epazote the Stephen King
horror any ties diverse over PA okay
this song pie is quiche
am I still a bit with the motive on
kinga Nicotra Bacchus okay today I only
know her ah my inspector prevent
anonymous nature pie actuary mom phone
camera a god what a Goku I could have a
son or wanna talk about or not the
Kurama
by unanimity I got hai ki conquer came
with a show in Santos that I captain
ahaab I was domotics has changed all the
politics of this kiddo for the moon to
their party it Tatem own that of course
Onaga got a gravity brandy shaloo that
by unique support any currency more
anonymity that we talk all day
Emily Emily Emily enough technical Tina
okay so me gentleman of I could scuttle
the three no no coach that one googled
am interested or Freud Okada gamma Kappa
nice the emotional folder active
kata-kata a no saga definitely connected
to a person in a con on his hoc
committee at Orono tomahto Montesano de
mi abbas ago Indian I cannot
[Music]
the time where I thought I was done with
resident evil as a franchise it played
such a huge fine igniting my love of
gaming but over the years it became
something totally unrecognizable to me
it felt like Capcom had misconstrued
what made Resident Evil 4 an outstanding
survival horror game and instead
capitalized on its newfound popularity
by pandering to the mainstream taste for
third-person action as a result the
Resident Evil franchise started to feel
like a series delivering unremarkable
lowest-common-denominator shooters
Capcom self-reflection seems to have
paid dividends in our time with it in
both gameplay and atmosphere Resident
Evil 7 showed echos of the original game
in cycled between the tension of horror
and the catharsis of action in between
these moments classic Resident Evil
pillars like exploration puzzle solving
and narrative exposition made it an
involving experience all the while the
stress of managing health and ammunition
simmered ready to boil over when the
ever-present threat of Jack Baker came
unexpectedly crashing through a wall
admittedly what we saw was a controlled
demo of a very specific section but if
Capcom is able to maintain this
experience across the entirety of the
game Resident Evil 7 could be the first
step on the road to redemption and this
is a sentiment that clearly isn't lost
on its developers Bob Cousy no kankakee
already masks a little more oh yeah no
no action that we talked aluminum's
kiddo Oh No bye Horatio dono you know
scary tow an average title so no hoorah
toasty perishability togarashi carita
imitates Quirino day sorry Lucas a
murder in the river so you got a today
yeah buddy Matano who can attend to the
caballo Mississippi Moon
not for Toshi not do enough what could
our home toys even touch this one who
I'm on oh it's good at that Timmy
diverse bookish Indian not totally
mastered a so much good to Annapolis
okay raw score sake Vamsi master APIs if
I'm not I don't know but so naka de
humahuaca considered tomecek sunomono
whatever read it an electron a modernist
the kokino or seven what aesthetic I had
no is she human mucho survival horror a
biohazard Ahmadis its massive you may
set your vehicle committed malicious
title room oh sweet Emily anywho not a
total tyrant I do do more to finish the
movie totally masterpiece no start a
pointillist Doha so this memory to car
Yuri Yudin to tell I buy all this for
you but we will give that 10 iconic what
a unit you need that's what I will do
more I take you to see a missing top
with you're not there by a lot of my
heart of portability delicate about it
especially I see it
after film night be super identity oh it
together I never be not it's ironic that
a series about survival finds itself in
a position where it needs to adapt to
remain relevant in light of the series
is recent missteps interest in Resident
Evil is waning so the stakes are high
for Capcom but his success of failure
could have a wider impact the profile of
Japan's most prominent video game
properties have been severely diminished
and the country as a whole continues to
turn away from big budget blockbusters
in favor of mobile games if there's one
thing you can give captain credit for
it's the company's decision to take
risks with what is arguably its most
valuable property Resident Evil is one
of the few remaining marquee japanese
franchises and with the renewed focus on
survival horror and a fresh perspective
it's reaching for relevance again this
is a make-or-break moment for Resident
Evil as a franchise and while his future
is still uncertain the return to its
roots may just be what he needs to carry
it through another 20 years
[Music]
[Music]